Thank you so much, Chris.
And thank you, Sahid.
Thank you both for
inviting me to speak.
And thanks to all of you for
taking a few minutes to listen.
I think this talk is
going to be a little bit
different from the ones
we've heard so far,
but I hope this provides
an interesting perspective.
As Chris mentioned,
I work at Atlassian,
and I work on the
HipChat product.
I'm the product manager there,
and I've been with that team
for about three months.
HipChat, if you are
not familiar with it,
is a chat tool built
for your team at work.
Another way to think
about it is it's
like IRC, except everybody at
your work is willing to use it,
instead of just the devs.
But it's fantastic at
bringing your whole community
into one place.
You can have persistent chat
rooms for teams, projects,
deploys, bugs, anything
you could think of.
And of course, you can chat
one-on-one with anybody
on your team.
You can share files, images,
links, and HipChat records
everything and makes it
searchable and easily findable
later.
HipChat runs on pretty
much everything.
Of course, we
started on the web,
but we also have Native Clients
for Windows, Mac, and Linux;
and you get it on
iOS and Android.
So pretty much anywhere
you are at any time,
you can be in contact with
your team using HipChat.
We found-- and this was
certainly the case with us
before we discovered HipChat--
that most people at work
are using some sort
of consumer tool
to communicate with
their colleagues.
I found that I did
this all the time.
So we decided to build
a better solution.
HipChat is built for business,
because your whole team
is already there.
There are tens of thousands
of teams around the world who
are using it to
collaborate today.
It's the first thing they
sign into in the morning.
They leave it open on
their desktop all day long.
They converse in it with their
colleagues until they go home,
and even after.
And it is the heartbeat
of those teams.
This was certainly
the case for us,
but we found that
there was a problem.
Any time we found ourselves
moving the conversation outside
of HipChat, we got frustrated.
It happened over and over again.
So as conversations got longer,
someone would inevitably say,
"well hey, let's
just talk about this
rather than typing for an hour."
Then we proceeded to
the negotiation phase.
So do you want to
use a real phone?
Or how about Skype?
What about a Hangout over here?
We could just go to
the conference room
and use a VC system?
Oh wait, OK, what
room are you in?
What's your login
on that system?
I invited you, have
you seen my invitation?
I don't see you logged
in, let me restart.
So inevitably, it
would take 10 minutes
to actually get this stuff done.
And by the time you actually
connected with the person
that you wanted
to talk to, you'd
forgotten what you wanted to
talk about in the first place.
So that's why we decided
to build HipChat Video.
You can now move a conversation
from text chat to video chat
with a single click
inside HipChat.
You can do video calls, screen
sharing, and audio calls
all right within
the application.
And so far, our
customers have loved it.
So that's really what
I'm here to talk about,
is how we built HipChat Video.
But here's the
tricky bit, we really
didn't build very
much of it, actually.
We ended up using a
video provider to power
all of HipChat
Video, and all we did
was integrate it
into the application.
We decided that running
a video platform
was not our core
competency, not where
we wanted to spend all of
our energy and our effort.
We wanted to build a great
experience, and a great chat
tool, and a great collaboration
tool, of which video
was a feature.
And we weren't
convinced that we could
do it better than the many great
companies that are starting up
right now, devoted
to that very problem.
We wanted to take advantage
of what they had done.
So we set out on a
journey about a year ago
to choose a provider
to work with,
and to integrate that
feature into our application.
I'm going to talk a little bit
about what we thought about
as we chose somebody, what we
have discovered as we rolled it
out, and I'm going to leave you
with a few of the lessons we
learned.
To start with, the most
important thing, and one
of the daunting
things that caused
us to want to work with
a provider to begin with
was platform support.
Because we have to work on all
those platforms, native apps,
all the browsers including
IE, including Safari,
we knew that vanilla WebRTC
was not going to be enough.
So we found somebody
who could provide us
a library and the plug-in
for the non-native support
browsers, and they would extract
away all that difference.
We could program to
one API, no matter
which browser we were
using, and it worked great.
They use WebRTC
everywhere they can,
they install a plug-in
where necessary,
and then I think they
have some fallback methods
for the very old versions of IE.
In the same way, we weren't
just building for the web,
we had five other platforms.
Luckily, we found
a provider that
provided a library that
supported Mac, Windows,
Linux, and iOS and
Android all natively.
So we had an SDK
for each of those.
They extracted
away a lot of pain
that we would have
had to go through
if we were trying to do
this entirely on our own.
That API is actually
the second thing
that we've thought really
long and hard about.
We actually spent a lot
of time experimenting
with multiple
providers to make sure
that they had an API
that was complete,
that was well documented, that
supported what we wanted to do,
and that was well supported.
And it was actually
amazing how many people
failed this simple test.
The features that
we cared about,
that was obviously another
major consideration.
We've started now with
one-to-one video chat,
but we know that we
want to go much further.
We want to move to group next,
and broadcast in the future,
and so we made sure
that we found somebody
who was heading in
that same direction,
and provided a lot
of those features.
We looked at how they handle
multi-party, how widely they
could scale, what technology
they use behind it,
and there have been
some great explanations
today about the architectures
that support that.
We also looked at things like
how they collected analytics,
and could we have them?
Could we actually
see how things were
performing inside
our application?
And quality measures as well.
Fourth, we cared a lot
about user experience.
We were trying to
solve a problem where
there was a lot of
sort of UX friction.
And so we wanted to
make sure that we
could make a smooth and
painless an experience
as possible to make it
feel like 100 percent
native part of the app.
So it was interesting,
because there
were a bunch of providers--
maybe not a bunch,
but there are some
providers-- that we
looked at that had
a standalone UX.
You couldn't really
modify very much.
Sometimes there was branding
that you couldn't get rid of.
Sometimes it would
launch a new process.
We found one that we could
integrate wholly into the app,
and as far as our
customers are concerned,
there is no difference between
HipChat and HipChat Video.
So not every provider
gives you the latitude
that you might want to build
the user interface that
fits best in your application.
And lastly, we were
looking for a company
whose primary business
model was providing video
as a service to us and others.
We were happy to pay for this.
We just wanted to make sure
that our incentives were aligned
with theirs as a
company, and that we
were going to go down
this road together,
because you are making
a long-term commitment.
And you want the team
to be responsive,
and fortunately the
folks we worked with
proved to be very responsive.
So how did it go?
It worked out fantastically
well from our perspective.
Once we had selected
a provider, we
had a prototype up and
running in a matter of weeks,
and it took several
months after that
to go from prototype to
shipping, But I guarantee you,
it would have taken possibly
an inordinate magnitude longer
to actually build support
for all five platforms,
for all the backend,
for multi-party support.
That was all stuff
that we just got
to take advantage of
someone else's great work.
And when we launched, we
supported all those platforms.
All the browsers,
all the native apps,
and all the mobile apps as well.
And that was a fantastic
thing, because of course
video as a feature
in your app, it's
sort of a network
effects kind of thing.
It's more valuable the
more people I can call.
So if we had a limit
and say, well, it
works in the Mac app and the
Windows app, but not in iOS
yet, then you're
automatically sort
of kneecapping your
feature to begin with.
So launching on all
platforms simultaneously
was really important to
us, and with the partner
we were able to do it.
So we launched HipChat
Video three months ago,
as I mentioned,
and user response
has been really, really good.
So just a few of the
reactions that we've
seen in that first
week, and since.
People are really valuing the
ability to stay within the app,
to use video in the context
that they already are.
We've had over 150,000
video calls placed
in three months, 2.5 million
minutes of conversations.
I didn't really
know what to expect
when we launched this thing.
I didn't have an
idea of the scale.
But when I looked this
number up, it blew my mind.
That is a lot of people
talking to each other
about a lot of really
important things.
The average call is
about 15 minutes long,
and there are plenty of calls
that are an hour or more.
So clearly, people are taking
advantage of this for meetings
at work, which is sort of
how we were using it as well,
so that makes sense.
In HipChat, we are
really doubling down
on this idea of
making great meetings.
We think that having a
tool like this, especially
for distributed teams, can make
meetings more efficient, less
painful, and just more useful by
bringing all your communication
channels into one context.
So that's what we're
thinking about.
So what did we learn?
Or what have we learned
so far in the year
or so that we thought
about selecting, and then
building, and then releasing
this feature inside our chat
application?
Well first, we figured
out that video is actually
really hard in the wild.
And we were insulated
from some of it
because we got to
work with somebody,
but still there was
all sorts of user error
that we weren't expecting.
I mean, we were
all web developers,
and all of a sudden you're
now dealing with hardware.
It's not complicated hardware,
but it's still hardware,
and it's not
something that I was
used to ever having to
do as a web developer.
But you've got to
worry about cameras,
you've got to worry
about drivers,
about the microphone,
you've got to worry about
other applications who
have stolen focus.
And these are things that,
no matter what happens,
the user is going to
blame your application.
So we had to work really hard to
try and smooth that experience
out.
And of course, with
video, especially
with peer-to-peer
video like WebRTC,
you're at the mercy
of the network.
And again, the user doesn't care
what the network looks like,
they just want
the thing to work.
And if it doesn't
work, it's your fault.
So that led us to
a second lesson,
which was we had to
monitor everything.
So we want a constantly
updating sense
of how the application is
performing out in the field.
And so we started looking at
things like calls attempted,
called completed, calls dropped,
looking at those ratios.
We looked for problem signs,
like repeated short calls
between the same two
people, or lots of drops,
or short calls that were
legitimately hung up.
But if somebody's only on
there for five seconds,
it's probably because
they can't hear
or they can't see or
something like that.
We monitored network quality and
audio quality and video quality
during the call,
and see how that
changes over time and with load.
And then lastly,
we also made sure
that we asked the users
how things were going.
So this is a pretty
standard UI, but as I'm
sure you've seen with
many other tools,
when the call ends
we say, "how was it?
How was the quality?
Please give us your
one to five rating.
If there's a problem, you
can leave some notes."
And we track and
record that over time
as well to make sure
that we're staying
at a high level of quality.
And fortunately, things have
been pretty good so far.
But thirdly, the
first two lessons
led to this third
one, which is, it's
really important to help
users help themselves.
So because the user is going
to blame your tool no matter
what goes wrong, it's
best to give them
as many ways out of a
problem as possible.
So we built in things into the
application like a Test Sound
button to make sure that
the speakers were turned on,
or their headset was plugged
in right or working correctly.
Indicators for your
mic, for the camera
display so you can actually
see what the camera is seeing
to make sure it's
actually working
the way you think it's working.
And then lastly, we
made sure that there
was really detailed logging that
a user can turn on and access,
and give to us if necessary.
And that's helped our
support guys a whole lot.
So I'll leave you with
three key takeaways
that we pulled out
of this process.
The first is the choice
of Building versus Buying.
And what we asked ourselves
was, was video the core
of our application?
Was it the most important
thing we were going to build?
And we decided that
it was a feature,
but it was not the core.
And secondly, we were
not in a position
that we could invest
to do it differently,
or better than the
whole ecosystem of you
guys out there who were
building these services already.
So we found a great
partner to work with.
Secondly, before
you choose, make
sure you look hard at
the SDK and the API
before you make a commitment.
You're going to be using
that API for a long time,
make sure it's something
you want to program against.
And lastly, remember that
the real world is messy.
So make it as easy as possible
for your users to self
diagnose, to give
you information,
to help you help them.
So that's how we
built HipChat Video.
I really appreciate
you guys listening,
and I hope you'll
go check it out.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]